مشاهدينا الان نتابع هذه الصور المباشره
من منطقه غازي عنتاب في تركيا حيث يواصل
عمال انقاذ عمليات البحث عن ناجين بين
الانقاض وبين ركام هذه المباني التي نهارت
بسبب الزلزال الضخم والمدمر الذي ضرب جنوب
تركيا وشمال غرب سوريا يوم امس الحصيه
الاجماليه مشاهدينا لعدد القتلى في
البلدين تجاوز الخمسه الاف قتيل بعد هزات
ارضيه عنيفه ضربت مناطق قريبه من الحدود
التركيه السوريه بلغت قوتها 7 درجات فاصله
خمسه درجات
وصبيحه هذا اليوم ايضا ضربت ضربه زلزال
مناطق في تركيا
ربما بلغت قوته سبعه سته درجات فاصله
خمست ايضا انهيار اكثر من 5000 و600 مبنى
في العديد من المدن بينها مباني من طوابق
عده تضم عائلات كبيره
هناك مخارج ايضا مشاهدينا من ان يستمر عدد
القتلى في الارتفاع بهذه الوتيره حتى ان
منظمه الصحه العالميه قدرت ان قرابه 20
الف قتيل ربما يكون قد سقطوا في هذه
الكارثه كما نشاهد المشاهدين هذه الصور
المباشره لعمليات الانقاذ في غازي عنتاب
التركيه واكثر من 5000 قتيل حتى الان في
سوريا جراء هذا الزلزال المدمر